one of these trader news networks oh the
king of trader news networks
fox news so let's let me see if i can
grab that clip there and if i can find
it
what was she was he on laura ingram yeah
he was on lauren okay here we go um so
here he was this is one of the the
subjects of the
of the search warrant and the subpoena
let's listen in the last week the
justice department has issued 40
subpoenas these two phones of trump
associates over january 6.
your response to this uh less than two
months before a midterm election will
come after yourself
that's that's the point though isn't it
i mean of course it's already been well
it's been publicly reported that i was
on the list of subpoenas in the new york
times
but so did they take his phone or his
mommy's phone that's well they he they
took his both his parents phone
well i guess all three right him his
mother and his father because remember
right the excuse the excuse that stephen
miller gave was you can't take my phone
because i am still on my parents plan
so
this guy
i don't know i don't even know it makes
no it makes no sense because here's the
thing well no in legal court you can
make the argument that the reason why
you can't convict me of crimes of stuff
i did on this phone is because it's not
really mine i don't actually right right
right
now you know god forbid that a i don't
know a phone carrier is able to say oh
look it's on this number yeah we don't
need to give you the other number right
we just give you the one number that's
in question i mean if you have
reasonable doubt that you need to look
at these numbers sure good i mean we
won't we won't
we won't uh try to fight you on this do
you think mommy went and bought him
another phone now that he's got i don't
know i mean that's a that's a that's a i
mean the iphone 14 is coming out soon so
who knows maybe they said that they said
the exact same thing though right i've
heard that that it's all [ __ ] that
there's nothing new about the 14 they're
just oh yeah well there's a there's a
couple things that are actually
different oh okay well maybe stephen
miller will get lucky in his mind he's a
good little fascist that is then his mom
might give him a phone i mean this guy
is pure evil and he is unwilling to in
the reason he is unwilling to admit he
will not admit to laura ingraham right
now on the show if the phone was
actually taken away it's because if he
does
then it will prove that there was
uh there was reason to suspect that he
was involved in whatever the crimes that
he's being you know looked at for right
well the reason why reason why they
would take a [ __ ] phone like that and
they would have a probe that direct
towards a specific phone here's the
reason why is because they have back end
other phones that show the [ __ ] crime
right they want to see who the [ __ ] he
was talking to right because there's
communication inside text message
threads to another person on another
phone right where he says this person
says this
in other words they're trying to track
down
they're trying to track down the chain
of communication it's what they're doing
they're trying to figure out who the
[ __ ] is the point of communication who's
giving the orders where and that's why
they're seizing all these [ __ ] phones
clark uh they took didn't they take
another one of clark's i believe they
yeah i think
yeah yeah i can't remember they're still
i mean well every time every time a
phone because the other thing too is
like if if it's not on tape
then these people who get their phones
taken away or their property taken away
seized for a search warrant or subpoena
uh
they can cause they can cast doubt right
because he says well that's what the new
york times was reporting but even in the
other video peter reveals that like the
reason that we know about these things
is not because these people at the doj
or the fbi saying hey hey call me
carlson yeah
they are admitting this and telling them
that oh hey just so you know they are
persecuting us tony they are [ __ ]
persecuting us for being an american
citizen who believes in the life liberty
and the pursuit of happiness oh yeah so
what we tried to stage a coup or what we
tried to overthrow the government or
what we tried to you know uh cause an
election to be you know uh invalid
these are the people or you know further
or more crimes worse crimes whatever
they may be
this is a group that will whine and
complain oh no i'm being persecuted i'm
being i mean my my my my my own rights
are being taken away from me yeah
because you [ __ ] broke the law or you
did something where you attempted to do
something to break a law and here's the
thing
you are the one who is openly admitting
we don't have some leak coming out of
the doj saying hey just so you know we
took away this person's phone and this
was person's phone in this way the only
reason we're finding out about this if
it's released in court documents that
are open to the public or the person who
is the owner of that device is revealing
to a news station hey they [ __ ] took
my stuff that is so [ __ ] and that's
important because here's why
is because
and this is why this is going to be so
beautiful in the end of this i'm telling
you folks i know it's going to take a
while but it is going to come all
crashing down on them because they're
using the flood the zone tactic like
they used for grab them by the [ __ ]
video like they used for the
charlottesville both sides thing they're
using the flood to zone tactic with a
bunch of [ __ ] and a bunch of lies
and they're just trying to get out there
to get as much media as possible but it
doesn't matter it's the [ __ ]
department of justice it's the fbi
they've got all the time and all the
resource in the world for the [ __ ]
find out stage and you reached it
stephen miller let's finish
that's the point right when are they
doing this right before the midterms
what is this all about what has it
always been about we've had this
conversation on your show many times
it's about using the power of the
justice department to influence our
elections it's about the partisanship
that has infected the doj at the highest
levels that everyone who treasures the
rule of law in america should be
terrified about what is happening to our
countrymen we have i told you last night
i was said they did not do this they did
not cause this before the midterms trump
did he delayed for almost two years
didn't want to give the documents and
then when the fbi and the doj was like
this is [ __ ] too far we have to come
get the [ __ ] it's because trump delayed
look
it's not their fault it is trump's fault
if he would have not taken the documents
or returned the documents and bill oops
sorry he got packed in the got packed up
in the boxes and went on the u-haul
truck sorry about that here you go this
would not even be an issue and it would
not be a problem for republicans to try
to weave their way around and say
oh this is no this isn't a big guys this
isn't a big deal he didn't do anything
wrong
it's their fault chris trump was the one
who we're on facebook she says he needs
a pardon blanket
if you can afford one he'd probably have
to ask his mom if you can get a little
uh
if he can have a party in her basement
oh my god